Hi, my name's grant.
And I'm the new host of visual politic and keeping with the theme of the
channel. I'm British, I'm wearing a cool shirt and on bold,
you're all welcome on this episode, the ruthless world of biological weapons.
Should we worry? Is there a biological warfare threat?
[Inaudible].
I'm going to tell you a story and I want you to think about whether this is a
real case or just some scifi movie, probably starring Nicholas cage,
Six places, and an important setting of several hundred thousand inhabitants.
I city nestled.
On a day of day.
Fog, a ship appear suddenly on a stealthily hidden inside the car.
Folk.
And with an aerosol dispersed in Kennan,
the ship starts expelling something strange into.
The air. It turns out.
While they're dispensing is nothing less than by
That's the end of my story. Is it real or is it not?
Well.
I described to you isn't the beginning of any Saifai film or any experiment by
Dr. Mengele.
I'm telling you something that really happened in 1950 and the city involved
with San Francisco, which goes a long way to explaining why it's.
Like that.
This army despairs over the city, over San Francisco, not once,
but at least six times the bacteria are bacillus subtilis and [inaudible]
Marston insists without the population of the setting. Knowing at that time,
these bacteria were not considered harmful to humans. However,
this experiment caused at least one person's death and the hospitalization of at
least 10.
What's more.
In the case of the bacteria. Massara Tara Marson sinensis.
It was proven that it was harmful to health.
And the use of experiments of this type have meant that to this day,
as a bacteria, which is very resistant to antibiotics,
and that usually produces serious outbreaks with some frequency
at this point, I'm sure many of you are asking yourself a question.
Why on earth would the United States decide to fumigate its own population with
bacteria? What were they hoping to do?
The keys phone.
And the biological weapons programs that United States put into action in 1943
and for at least 20 years,
between 1949 and 1969 gem tests were conducted for war purposes,
which goes a long way to explaining why America is like that.
Now your tests that were carried out on cities using the civilian population
themselves as unwitting, Guinea pigs. Yes, yes.
No.
The one think for a moment that they were the first,
nor the last nor the pioneers,
it's something that's been in place for many years.
Many years.
Want to know more about the ruthless world,
biological weapons and the threat they can really pose.
Do you think that in today's world you're prepared to face a possible biological
attack? Why don't you check.
Okay. This video.
Biological weapons, the murkiest military history,
before we begin this story, here's some light relief.
The development and experimentation of biological weapons has been been since
1975 by the convention on the prohibition of the development
production and stockpiling of bacteriological,
bacterial and toxin weapons and on their destruction.
That's what that agreement is known as always snappy these agreements.
And practice.
The vast majority of the world's countries have stopped developing and
experimenting with them, which is new to them. But up until 1975,
the real several countries that developed,
and in some cases even use these types of weapons with some frequency.
We're talking mostly about the United States, the Soviet union and Japan,
And they weren't pioneers long before these powers launched their
bacteriological development plans for military purposes,
biological weapons already had a long, long history.
First of biological weapons date back to at least the 16th century BC with the
headaches.
There is also evidence that their common use as early as the fourth century BC,
when the site, the inspired, poisoned arrows, their enemies,
it was also a normal that it was common for the peasants, the Greeks,
and the Romans to poison the Wells and water sources of their enemies with dead
animals that had been killed by infectious diseases.
Something similar was done with the talk tars in the 14th century,
they threw plague infected bodies on the general disease and cafes. Similarly,
the British gave blankets infected with smallpox to native American Indians and
the 18th century. And on behalf of Britain would like to say, sorry,
that's something you're going to hear a lot during the course of these videos.
But of course.
We don't have to go so far back in time to observe frequent use of biological
weapons.
Japan used this type of weaponry extensively during the first half of the 20th
century.
The.
Empire of Japan even had a specific unit,
the seven three one to investigate the effects of certain bacteria and viruses
on 11 prisoners.
These passages were then used indiscriminately during the Asian invasion
campaigns. For example, in 1939,
Japan used the bacteria salmonella typhi to pollute water reservoirs in the
former Soviet union.
In fact.
As because of this history, because of this growing use of biological weapons,
but United States established its own program in 1943,
right in the middle of world war II, a program that remained active for decades.
And that leaves the American power with the questionable distinction as the most
advanced country in terms of biological warfare technology.
The question is at what price,
how did we get to that point? Well, hold onto your chair. And in my case,
hairpiece, because there's a lot to talk about here and you know what,
I'm pretty sure that some of you are in for a nasty shock.
If the story of what happened in San Francisco that we told you at the beginning
of this video has already surprised you, what comes next is even worse.
Let's take a loop.
[inaudible].
Citizens.
Laboratory, Guinea, pigs.
The San Francisco.
Thing. Wasn't just a one-off right.
Can you believe it?
Because it States with biological weapons and also chemical weapons were
relatively common for years.
The main objective of these tests was to understand how the population would be
affected and the spread of damage that the biological attack of the enemy or
terrorists could have.
Wow.
Is that to advance such research,
the us military released bacteria that were considered harmless or an
Oculus known as replacement agents, sometimes alongside chemicals as well.
And then the air was analyzed to understand how far and in what concentration
the agent.
Okay.
Definitely. However,
some American field tests were not always particularly surgical or precise,
something that America has kept up to this
During 1957 and 1958,
the U S army flew low altitude aircraft in areas such as St.
Louis and Minnesota.
But that's the thing I'm mixture of Pat me himself and zinc,
sulfate over urban areas. And for those of you who don't know,
cadmium is toxic and carcinogenic, I should know that's how I lost my hair.
The point is that these experiments were conducted on a completely unprepared
civilian population, mainly on black minority and low income neighborhoods.
These aerosols could be spread over large areas.
Submarines could release aerosols near coastal cities.
But if you can believe it is not all and different parts of the country,
similar experiments continue to take place until 1968,
1968. You can probably guess the consequences years later,
several studies observed an increase in the incidents of various cancers in the
areas where these experiments were conducted
And wait for the best part. When people questioned the strange clouds and Hayes,
the us government basically told people that those planes were actually
conducting an experiment to cover the settees and a kind of fog that would hate
these cities in the face of an airstrike. Oh my God,
who on earth can think of fumigating the civilian population from planes just to
conduct an experiment. It's crazy. It is crazy.
But if this seems a radius to you,
wait till you see what they did in 1966 in New York city itself.
[Inaudible].
Several experiments were conducted with the bacteria are bacillus subtilis on
the New York subway during rush hour. And this case,
the experiments consisted of lunging bacteria filled bulbs onto the tracks and
say,
the trains themselves are through the air ducts to see how far and how bluntly
our real biological attack could expand. If the subway were a target.
These bulbs as broke, released.
Millions of bacteria into the air, not in many cases,
entered the trains and were transported miles and miles through the subsoil of
the city.
The study found that if a biological attack had the New York subway as a target,
millions of people would be exposed to this disease.
Therefore the spread of the attack could reach most of them.
Yes.
You heard that right?
Real tests with real bacteriological charges on the New York city,
subway and instigated by the U S government. But then again, are you surprised?
[Inaudible].
Just as impressed at the New York city hall, because far from morning,
the local authorities, it was not until 1980.
So the New York government became aware of these tests with bacteria in there.
[Inaudible].
A couple of you will be thinking, okay, okay, let's see, this is terrible.
And maybe, maybe reprehensible, but let's get to the point.
So I've all these exercises at least improve the United States ability to deal
with a biological attack. How prepared is the country and the world to date,
what's such an attack pose a global threat. Well, let's investigate.
A reality check despite everything.
So is the U S ready? It will come as a surprise to absolutely. No.
One of the answer is not really.
If you think that all these experiments we've seen have made America truly
prepared to deal with a real biological attack today, you are very wrong.
At least that's what many of us biodefense experts say, listen up.
The census that we haven't fully prepared if you've had an attack.
And even if we had the treatment or the vaccine that everyone needed,
we don't have the capacity to get that to 330 million Americans,
us government official not authorized to speak on record.
But how is it possible that a country that invests $6 billion in biodefense
every year is not prepared for a biological attack?
Well.
Understand us. We will give you an example with smallpox,
a deadly disease caused by the very of virus.
There's already been eradicated in the wild,
but which is preserved and laboratories,
especially in the U S and Russian laboratory.
The virus was suddenly released in a setting whether accidentally or
intentionally its initial expansion would be virtually impossible to detect and
stop since between the attack and the onset of the first symptoms.
There's an incubation period of several days during which the virus will be
moving within the city at its leaf.
Yes.
And then when you finally realized that biological attack has occurred,
you could already have hundreds and hundreds, thousands,
and thousands of people infected people who would suddenly become real
biological weapons and their own rights they themselves would inadvertently
spread the virus. And in fact, many more people
To give you an idea of their defenses.
The United States currently has a real stock of just over 15 million units of
the smallpox vaccine. Vaccines are practically ready to use at any time,
but what this protect against a possible biological attack?
Well, the truth is it's not at all clear.
You see.
The time it would take to detect the virus will launch a massive vaccination
campaign in the effected city or region,
and actually vaccinate all its inhabitants would be considerable. Of course,
during that period, the number of infections would continue to spread.
And this way, dozens,
perhaps hundreds of thousands of people would become infected as a result of the
biological attack.
Before the protective measures began to work more over an increasingly
interconnected world,
it would be just a matter of days before the virus spreads across the country
and even across the globe.
Luke.
Of course there are just over 15 million vaccines available and the whole of the
United States that means even in the country with the world's largest reserves,
barely over 7% of the population could be vaccinated.
And still.
Is not. The only problem is that despite the 50 million stock,
only 90,000 doses would be available for immediate use in a matter of days,
just 90,000 doses.
And the situation.
Is merit at the international level.
To give you.
An idea is estimated that worldwide, there are 60 million more doses in stock.
So imagine that as a result of a biological attack or an accident,
there was a global outbreak. It would be.
Ridiculous.
Take into account that the interconnection between territories and countries is
now infinitely greater than at the time of any of the natural outbreaks of this
virus before it was eradicated,
the results could actually pose a threat to humanity itself.
So what's my point here.
SARS COVID 19 has just been a good example of the viruses ability to spread in
our world today.
But putting.
This really marquee SU site,
there is another issue that worries biosecurity experts just as much,
or if possible, even more.
I'm talking about the simplicity and cheekness of being able to genetically edit
pathogens Lake of bacteria and viruses.
In recent years.
Progress has been made in this area thanks to a new method of genetic editing
called CRISPR.
There's a technique that allows genes to be edited much more accurately,
quickly,
and also more cheaply than the genetic editing technology that existed up until
a few years ago.
And he can consists mainly of using an enzyme called cast knife to cut the
thread, the DNA sequence, wherever you want,
thus giving you the possibility of splicing new genetic material and to the gap
material that may belong to another completely different bacteria or virus.
So that features can be added or removed artificially.
Anyone who's seen the masterpiece that has the original Jurassic park will know
exactly what I'm talking about.
It would.
Be similar to taking some old trousers that no longer fits us,
cutting the fabric and putting in a piece in between them to make them bigger.
Only that fabric can be of another completely different garment and with
different characteristics.
However, this system has reduced.
Costs for the average cost of such operations being just over $3,000 on average
operations, that with old techniques would have cost much more. So come on.
These weapons don't require military budgets of hundreds, of billions,
of dollars, nor hundreds of soldiers, nor fleets of drones,
nor aircraft carriers, just alum,
and some small investment to create absolute chaos.
It's not just a matter of reduced costs.
This technique has also allowed the process to be shortened robotic 18 months to
just over three weeks, three weeks.
There's been a revolution in the field of biomedicine.
One with very positive results.
For example.
As reduced and simplified the modification of plant genomes to make them
resistant to pests and bacteria,
thereby ensuring food security and many impoverished countries that are
constantly suffering from such disease.
Masters.
Even though the existence of CRISPR CAS nine is undoubtedly positive.
What really unsettles biosecurity experts is what could happen if this genetic
editing system is used at advanced levels by the wrong people.
If a.
Country or even on lone terrorist organization,
secretly use this method to create genetically modified bacteria or viruses to
make them more resistant,
more lethal or more contagious in order to use them as biological weapons,
we could be facing a challenge to biosecurity of astronomical magnet.
Oh, the editing of genomes and viruses or bacteria is not an easy task.
CRISPR Castlemaine has simplified and shortened the process compared to older
techniques.
That is why it is essential to closely monitor who and what these techniques are
using.
See if we've learned anything from the SARS COVID 19 coronavirus pandemic. Okay.
So that's even the country's supposedly best equipped and biosecurity can suffer
catastrophic.
That's precisely why many of us are wondering,
could the world today be more vulnerable than ever to biological threats?
What measures should we take to try and control this threat?
Do you think your country could be overcome a large-scale biological attack as
always ours, the questions and yours, the answers.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe,
donate to there for brand new videos that we put every week. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tones.
Finally,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our messaging,
providing independent political coverage. And as always,
I'll see you in the next video, don't forget to like subscribe.
And most importantly washer go down mountains.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.
Aerosols could be spread over large areas.
Marines could release aerosols near coastal city.